hello i'm glad to be here today to talk
to you about
our project related to how we find
toxicologically significant compounds
using in vitro bioassays and high
resolution mass spectrometry this
project is a joint collaboration between
my lab
with gabby black taking a key
experimental role and labs that do
bioassays mike dennison and chris
vogel's labs and guochon he did a lot of
the
bio essay results that we're going to
talk about today
so as you can see from the background of
this slide we're going to be talking
about wildfires in residential areas and
the impacts that they cause but before
we do that i'd like to just give an
overview of what it is that my lab is up
to these days and how it might be of
interest to those of you who are
watching this today
so
my research starts with a focus on
chemicals that we put in products things
that we use in our houses and to build
our houses and
so forth because we would like to
understand how we make better choices
about chemicals in our products based on
their ultimate environmental impacts and
there are many different ways that these
compounds can impact us
they can be disposed of down the sewer
for things that are used in laundry
products or dishwashing detergents
things like that
they can be disposed of in solid waste
at the end of their life they can
accumulate in our houses for example in
the dust or in the furniture in the foam
they might be directly applied out of
doors um like uh ant control around your
home they might burn up in a wildfire as
we'll be talking about today each of
those pathways can can
uh enter intervening compartments like
wastewater
they can be converted into biogas and
biomethane turned into biosolids or
compost and could be run off via
stormwater
each of those compounds in each of those
media then are subject to possible
transformation in various processes that
happen in the environment uh such as
biodegradation combustion
or other abiotic reactions that happen
for instance photolysis
and so in the end we
when we sample the environment ambient
water ambient air ambient soil what we
find is that we're sampling not just the
mix of chemicals that we started with
but a complex mixture of things that
have been sliced and diced by various
environmental reaction processes and so
that's where we're looking for impacts
and what we want to know is are these
compartments air water and soil are they
healthy for people who are exposed to
them or who consume them and
there's lots of different ways we could
assess this we could measure the
toxicity towards some
particular organism like an aquatic
invertebrate for example in a sediment
test
we might just assess whether they cause
particular biological changes like
mutagenicity or endocrine disruption
our goal in our lab in the red box is to
identify the compounds that are
responsible for that activity and
ultimately to try to connect them back
to the product choices that we've made
in order to give feedback to people who
make these products to tell them that
chemical a is a more safe or greener
alternative than chemical b
so that's the big picture of what we're
trying to do and i've chosen today to
talk about one specific project but i
wanted to provide some examples of other
things that we're doing in my lab at the
moment
so the next slide just tells us
provides two specific examples of other
projects that i won't be talking about
today the one on the left is our
superfund research program many of the
methods that are talked about today are
developed under that program um i'm the
deputy director of that program the
director bruce hammack and i have worked
together for a number of years and it's
really a collaboration between engineers
analytical chemists and people who do
mechanistic bioassays and mechanistic
biological impact studies and a lot of
this work and workflow that i'm going to
be talking about today grew out of that
effort
on the right-hand side i've just
highlighted a big project which we're
currently engaged in in which we're
measuring uh
drinking water samples treated drinking
water from eight different communities
in california at multiple time points
in each of those areas we have 15
households participating and we're doing
comprehensive non-target chemical
analysis of drinking water using the
kinds of techniques i'm going to be
talking about today those results are
still in process and in the center i've
just listed some other ongoing projects
that i don't really have time to talk
about today
so before we get to the specific project
i wanted to try to connect what i'm
going to be talking about to those of
you who might be watching this webinar i
know that a number of people might be
looking for for example business
opportunities related to
non-target chemical analysis because
it's not as widespread as targeted
analysis at the moment
and i wanted to draw your attention to
the way in which trends and policies
specifically in california but possibly
other places are colliding to make
non-target analysis and bioassays
kind of a hot topic so in california we
had a really large drought in the
2014-2015 period a lot of our aquifers
were drawn down
and there were wells that went dry and
so that caused the state to grapple with
this idea of sustainable groundwater
management what do we have to do to keep
our aquifer sustainable and what they
came up with was this uh sigma
sustainable groundwater management act
which says that you need to make sure
that your pumping of water from the
aquifer is sustainable and rather than
you know your two choices to do that are
to curtail use or to increase supply and
a lot of districts are trying to
increase their supply by recharging
their aquifers with a variety of water
sources including treated wastewater
agricultural return water storm water
etc
at the same time the state of california
another arm of the state of california
the state water resources control board
has adopted a water quality control
policy which says among other things
that you will test these waters that
might be used in an aquifer recharge
project for not only target compounds
like we might expect them to but also to
look for particular in vitro bioassay
results like estrogen receptor ag and
agonism and aero hydrocarbon receptor
agonism and so that's a water-based
example of the kinds of detective work
we're going to be talking about today
so this wildfire study grew out of the
the firestorm um in in 2017 in
california
and in the aftermath of those fires
there were a lot of questions about how
safe it was to go back in and
effectively sift through these ashes um
we know that
obviously a home fire is one thing but
an entire neighborhood burning down at
very high temperature in a wildfire is
another and it wasn't clear that when
you burn down the households that are
constructed from all these different
synthetic materials and containing
things like pesticides and solvents and
electrical insulation and so forth that
all of those compounds might not end up
in the ash and pose an extra risk to
people who are trying to
you know workers who are trying to
renovate the site or people who are
trying to reoccupy the site
so our goal was to understand whether
the ash from these residential wildfires
was intrinsically more harmful than the
ash that might be derived from a normal
forest-based wildfire
so to answer that question we designed a
study in which we took samples ranging
from the upper part of the map in the
center shows robert lewis stevenson
state park that serves as our
undeveloped reference site in this in
this case it was the northern boundary
of this particular piece of the fire and
the prevailing winds during this fire
were largely from the northeast to the
southwest so
angling down to the left in the map
there and so there's a transect of sites
at each general location we took three
samples so there's a total of five sites
four of them developed one of them
undeveloped at each site we have three
different samples and then we we
composited uh samples from these homes
and a couple of representative destroyed
homes are shown in photos on the left
and this fire destroyed over 5600
structures caused 22 deaths
and we were trying to understand whether
the sites in yellow
up at the top were really different in
their chemical composition and in their
biological impacts compared to the urban
or or residential sites
so what i want to do today is to show
you how we do this analysis
we have a unified workflow that applies
to both lc and gc high resolution mass
spectrometry data and then how we
connect that to the bioassay results
that we obtain and and then to just talk
a little bit about the chemical
composition difference and whether that
matters to what we're trying to say
something about which is toxicity
and as i've already mentioned we're
using these two instrumental platforms
both lc and gc
instruments and
we've got these total of 15 sites
12 of them with residences that were
destroyed
so to provide an overview of our
analytical method it's a fairly
straightforward and
not all that exciting
set of
sample processing so we take sieved ash
samples from these sites
we do a quick sonication extraction
sequenced
with hexane acetone and then acetone we
evaporate that filter it
we to do the lc side we do a solvent
exchange um on the gc side we add an
internal standard there's a series of
internal standards added to the to the
lc samples um the analysis is done on
two quadrupole time-of-flight
instruments the agilent 6530 lc and the
agilent 7200b
gc
the
lc samples are cleaned up
and and then run in both esi positive
and esi negative
and we run them initially in full scan
and then we go back and do targeted msms
on priority features and the priority
features are the ones that are related
to the bioassay activity as all is all
described
in our data acquisition on the gc side
we're doing this in electron ionization
mode and we've got both a target screen
for some compounds that we knew would be
likely important and also
non-target or suspect screening
so i alluded to this unified data
analysis workflow
and so here it is
this workflow allows us to take data
files that come from our instrument
these are agilent.d files and we take
them through an analysis base file
converter to make them into a
format that can be read by ms dial ms
dial is
a
program that was initially developed in
a collaboration between
a japanese institute and the uc davis
west coast metabolomic center
and it it aligns and deconvolutes the
the data it's designed for metabolomics
but we use it for what you might think
of as exposomics and then after we have
uh aligned features especially aligned
features that are of interest given
their res relationship to bio essay
results we take those same data and we
put them into another program known as
msfinder
and i've provided citations to the
development of both of those on this
slide if you're interested so these are
freely downloaded program downloadable
programs um
available through the west coast
metabolomic center website and and other
places as well
and then
in the end we try to annotate these
features and understand how they're
related to
the bioassay results
recently we've developed another branch
of this process in which we take
our agilent.d files and we use
the qualitative analysis programs that
agilent
has developed to
create chef files compound exchange
format files and these chef files can be
taken directly into sirius csi finger id
which is an alternative platform for in
silico analysis and
we're really enjoying and using that
workflow it's very effective but i'm not
going to be able to talk about it much
today because i've got too much to cover
but it's important to know that
especially once you get to this in
silico
msms analysis stage for non-target it's
important to use multiple platforms and
cross-compare the results that you get
and as you'll see we're still working on
that piece of this particular puzzle
so why do we use this workflow instead
of the workflows that are available
through
agilent or through other um non
you know
open source
programs and the the short answer is is
that because we're using both lc and gc
data and we want to merge those two data
streams having a single programming
approach which allows us to process both
sets of data in a consistent way is a
huge advantage for us and that's really
the fundamental thing behind this
because the ms dial allows us to treat
those two data sets more or less
equivalently and as you'll see we've
had some success in in both of those
directions in terms of identification
and and elucidation
and the other thing that we've noticed
uh consistently is that
when we're talking about non-targets
assigning the molecular formula to a
candidate structure using both ms-1 and
ms-2 data is uh much more robust and
much more likely to yield
an unambiguously correct molecular
formula based on our testing with known
compounds that we pretend that we don't
know and verify the molecular formula
assignment
so brief two slides about the bioassays
that we're going to be talking about um
the first set of bias bioassays are
referred to as chemically activated
luciferase bioassays
they're done in something like a 96 well
microplate and you've got cells in those
microplates that have
either aero hydrocarbon receptor
estrogen receptor or androgen receptor
these are the three
k lox assays that are the subject of
this talk
and what happens is when there is an
agonist that is something which binds to
that receptor
the
cells have been engineered to express uh
luciferase and
make light as you'll see in the bottom
right panel and so we then see a light
intensity as a measure of how much
binding there is so agonism is when the
chemical extract loose
evidences more activity than it than it
had in the control and sometimes we see
the opposite we see antagonism where the
response is actually suppressed and that
can also happen in a case where the
chemical blocks the binding of
of something to the receptor for
instance
estradiol to the estrogen receptor or
testosterone to the androgen receptor
and it actually reduces the activity
and that's referred to as antagonism and
we'll see some of both of those effects
in the data
these essays are all done
by go chang-hee in mike dennison's lab
here at uc davis
the second cellular model that we're
working with is out of chris vogel's lab
it's a
respiratory macrophage
model and the idea is that chemicals
once again it's mediated by this aero
hydrocarbon receptor but then what we're
looking for are
genetic markers
in either increase or decrease in the
expression of
il-8 cox-2 or sip-1a1 these are markers
of
inflammation uh apoptosis metabolism
oxidative stress and other things that
might be uh problematic notice that all
of these things could be normal
physiological responses potentially but
they are expressing a significant change
above baseline and in the presence of an
active compound so both of these kinds
of assays we think of them as being
necessary but not sufficient conditions
for toxicity
if if things bind to the aero
hydrocarbon receptor there is a chance
that they're toxic in the same way that
pcbs and dioxins are or there's a chance
that they would normally be metabolized
by this by the system and wouldn't be of
toxic significance that's just one
example of how they might not be of
toxic significance
so i'm going to go through three slides
summarizing the six different bioassays
we have three macrophage bioassays and
three
k lux style bioassays and each of these
three slides is configured the same way
the 12 residential sites are shown there
you'll see that there's these five four
neighborhoods cough larp mws and tbs
and then there's the one undeveloped
site which is from that state park
robert lewis-stevenson park and then on
the far right is the positive control
and on the far left is the negative
control
and the stars the asterisks on this plot
indicates statistically significant
difference uh from the uh negative
control
and so what we see is that first there's
no systematic difference between the
undeveloped sites and the residential
sites if anything the the most active
sample is is one of our undeveloped
sites uh but there are several of the
residential sites that have
elevated activity both with respect to
cytochrome p450 and with respect to aero
hydrocarbon receptor
agonism
there are far fewer statistically
significant effects in the il-8 and
cox-2 assays but there were a couple of
sites and the same sites that we saw
previously
as being
highly elevated for ahr and sip1a1
and then the third pair
is the estrogen receptor and androgen
receptor assays and
in this slide the positive control is
not shown because as you'll see the
bioassay responses are much smaller and
quite a number of them are negative this
is that antagonistic effect that i was
discussing earlier and so when we see a
negative response like this what it
means is that there's some leftover
testosterone or
estradiol in the system and the presence
of the extract is actually suppressing
that compared to the controls
now these bioassays
were highly intercorrelated with each
other and this totally makes sense
because the the cox2 and the il-8 and
the sip1a1 are all mediated through the
aero hydrocarbon receptor
and even though these assays were done
in different labs the red
shaded areas show us the strong
statistically significant positive
correlation between the
the hr mediated assays in the two
different labs and then we see that
there's a negative
connection between many of the assays
that are in red above
and the estrogen receptor and androgen
receptor assays and this is because we
see this antagonism effect
so now to get into the chemical
results um so this is what an ms dial
alignment looks like what we're looking
at in the in the middle the series of
green dots those are our aligned
features from our gcei data
and we've we've aligned them based on
retention index
to allow us to match to the nist library
based on both retention index and on
mass spectral
library match
above that you will see a bar chart
which shows the presence of the
abundance of that particular feature so
in this case we're looking at a
feature number 425 which is uh
methylmercapto benzothiazole
and you see that that was present in the
ash at much higher abundance than it was
in either mix or mega which are two of
our standards which contain a number of
target compounds so what that tells us
is this compound was not one of our
target compounds and it wasn't present
in the blank in any appreciable way and
so this is an evidence that this
compound is is real and found in the ash
on the bottom right you see the ei mass
spectral match um and you see
what the retention index um was on the
on the top right you see an ei
similarity score um in
on a scale of a thousand so this is a
pretty good uh match of a of a
non-target feature
and so
what we then do is we take the abundance
of all these different aligned features
and we look for how they're connected to
bio essay responses
before i go there though i want to just
show you one of the quality control
things we do with this gcei data so
we can we have a number of uh polycyclic
aromatic hydrocarbons as target
compounds in this analysis and so on the
y-axis of each of these six graphs is
the area count we got out of the agilent
quantitative analysis program
four known target compounds that are
labeled these six compounds that are
labeled here
on the
x-axis are the ms-style area counts for
things that were automatically
identified without telling the program
that these were these compounds it
pulled these out and it identified them
and it came up with an area count that
is strongly linearly related to the
area count that we got from the
quantitative analysis program so you can
think of the y-axis as representing the
proper quantitation of these things and
you can think of the x-axis as as the um
you know
non-non-proper improper quantitation but
what it tells us is that when we have a
non-target feature which has a
particular area that we expect that area
count to be strongly related to the
quantity of chemical in the sample and
that's important because it tells us
that we can look for correlations
between the abundances in the non-target
data and the bioassay response so this
is uh hand waving to show that we can
use these area counts in a quantitative
way
so
just to summarize all of the results
that we got out of this
here i've shown a table which just
counts the number of compounds which we
pulled out of the data in various ways
and and what happened after we filtered
and what was related to bioassays
so
the three streams of data are the gc
electron ionization the liquid
chromatography with electrospray
positive and electrospray negative
what you can see is that there were
between hundreds and thousands of
aligned features that were pulled out of
that sample set we do a series of
quality control processes on those align
features we remove things with low
signal to noise we remove things that
are present in the blank at an
appreciable level we remove things that
aren't present in replicate injections
in the case of lc
and then we with that remaining set of
features which is still in the hundreds
to thousands
domain what we're looking for is
either a
correlation
between the response and and in this
case we're using uh spearman rank order
correlations between the bio essay
responses and the abundance of a feature
what we see just to focus in on the
sip1a1 line just so you can understand
what these numbers mean
we're looking at the gcei column sip1a1
and what that tells you is that there
were 33 features out of the 407 that
passed our filter that were positively
correlated with cytochrome p450 activity
at the 95 confidence level and there
were 11 features that were negatively
correlated with
the sip 1a1 response and at the 95
confidence level and then the last
number there the one that's labeled en
is stands for elastic net regression
elastic net regression is a technique
which is a is a reduction technique it's
like a lasso regression and it uh
you'll see it's pretty effective in
identifying out of
this kind of data where you have many
many descriptors and relatively few
samples it's a very good technique for
identifying significant things and so
there were 13 things that the elastic
net regression procedure picked out and
there's a significant overlap between
the correlated features and the elastic
net selected features so for each of our
six assays and each of our three
instrumental platforms you can see we
have varying numbers of positive and
negative correlations and the elastic
net regression in a number of cases
return none
no features zero features that were
related to that particular bio essay
endpoint so you'll see in general the
elastic net procedure is stingier in
assigning things and and later on you'll
see that it has a better performance in
terms of identifying things in in final
so out of those hundreds to thousands of
features if we look at what's actually
related to bioassays we've got a much
more manageable set between 76 and 276
compounds for the three different uh
platforms now you'll see that there's
many compounds that are
higher in the samples that are
residential than the ones that were in
the undeveloped areas but as we'll also
see later there's not a lot of
connection between those compounds and
the bio assay results that we looked at
so let's zoom in a little bit to think
about those compounds which um have
a significant relation to bioassay
results many of them
so here we're specifically looking at
aero hydrocarbon receptor
binding
results and there were 76 gc compounds
which had a statistically significant
relationship to aero hydrocarbon
receptor activity and you'll see that a
lot of these things are not surprising
in their ability to activate the aero
hydrocarbon receptor because they're
aromatic hydrocarbons and so lots of
pahs and things that are on our target
list that we knew already would be
significant in this regard um showed up
as significant so you know there's no
new information content there but on the
other hand if we already know all the
things to look for then we've
satisfied ourselves in some way that um
we're not missing anything right
but not all the suspects were quite so
usual so some of these are three
compounds which were statistically
related to bioassay response they're
also not
looking at their structures not
surprising that they might activate
these receptors
these are compounds that were not in our
standards but with for which we got good
matches with retention index and
ms
the
spectra for the electron ionization in
the gc
so we have many more of these these are
just three examples
so the real question though is how did
we do in terms of finding compounds that
might actually activate these receptors
because the goal here is to fish out of
complex environmental samples
the compounds that matter and there's
lots of reasons why you think that might
not work
interactions between chemicals mixture
effects
inability to detect the right compounds
using whatever ionization approach we've
we've selected so this
table is kind of the summary of the work
that we did and it i'm going to try to
go through it a bit more slowly
so we saw and here we're focusing on the
on the gc uh ei data and and in this
data um there were remember 407 features
and there's a database talks 21 which
you may be familiar with which is a an
epa
hosted
database nih
hosted database that
is an assessment of many many different
bioassay responses and so there's
several thousand compounds in tox 21
that have been run on the exact same k
lox aero hydrocarbon receptor assay that
we ran in this uh study and so what we
see is among the entire population of
407 compounds that
were identified in the ash samples and
passed our various filter criteria only
15 of those are known to be ahr agonists
given the tax 21 results so of our total
detected universe something less than
four percent of the compounds activated
the aero hydrocarbon receptor
if we look instead only at the
population that was statistically
significantly correlated with
the bioassay results
there were four of those compounds out
of 17 that were
correlated were in the tox-21 database
and known to be ahr agonists so that
means 23
of the compounds
among the compounds that were correlated
were
known to be
actually active in the way that this
assay is is looking for
and then in elastic net we found about
the same performance there were only
five compounds returned by the elastic
back procedure and only one of those was
in the tox-21 as a known agonist but the
problem here is the tox-21 coverage of
our 407 compounds is not that great and
so we tried to expand our coverage so
the first thing we did is mike dennison
is the developer of this k lux aero
hydrocarbon receptor
assay that we that we're using and his
lab
through previous nih grants has surveyed
over 300 000 compounds for aero
hydrocarbon receptor activity and we
recently assembled a database of those
results and there's something like 7000
active compounds which is much larger
than the active compound set in talks
21.
and so when we look at that database the
ucd database
we get a much higher
fraction in well in all of the bins but
you can see that the performance goes up
but then the last thing we did was
compounds that weren't in talks 21 and
weren't in the uc davis database
were things that we could test ourselves
and so what we did is for the compounds
that we still didn't know whether they
were active or not but they were
correlated and we could get pure
standards we bought some pure standards
and we tested them
and
the estrogen receptor results here are
are similar but we just have a much less
uh significant database and so the
results look about the same as they did
for tox 21 only but we don't have this
additional ucd database or the target
tests for that piece so i can't provide
the last column of the table
so we went out and we bought five
compounds and we tested them on the
calex ahr
assay and what we found was that all
five of them had statistically
significant aero hydrocarbon receptor
agonist activity at different levels
here so you can see in the far right
column the prob value of the difference
between
the
assay result and the blank which is a
solvent blank
and in all but
two of these cases these
tests were statistically significant at
the 95 level and so
um what we confirmed was that this
technique this relationship of
non-target features to
to bioassay results that we obtain on
whole samples these samples weren't
fractionated in any way they were just
tested straight up on the assays we used
statistical procedures to fish things
out and as you see we had a very high
fraction of those compounds subsequently
proven to be active on the
receptor assay that we
fished them out with
and so this suggests that we can indeed
do what we're trying to do which is test
hole samples use statistical procedures
find the unknown compounds and identify
them and confirm their presence in the
samples even when we have no prior
information about the compound's
biological activity
in question
so that's
been focused on the gc results and
frankly we have the best and most
comprehensive results for the gcei data
because and it's also probably a
function of the aero hydrocarbon
receptor test is the place we have the
best database and the compounds that are
in that
that are active in the aero hydrocarbon
receptor tend to be gc-able in a way
that the lc compounds aren't um
but i wanted to spend at least a couple
of minutes talking about how we do the
non-target
in silico annotation using msfinder
so we took our features which were
correlated with bioassay outcomes or
or were selected by the elastic not
regression procedure and we went back
and we tried to do targeted msms
experiments on all of them
we got a fairly low coverage of
successful targeted msms experiments
however
because
there's low abundance of some of these
things
and it's hard to get enough fragment
abundance the other thing that's
challenging is that many of these
molecular formula are pretty generic
they're they're cho or cnho type
compounds which
have many many possible structures and
not a lot of highly detailed
fragmentation
and therefore
they're not easy to nail down
but here i'm just providing one example
of how ms finder works we've taken a
particular feature out of our
alignment that we know to be
statistically important and related to
the bioassay results and we find that it
has an empirical formula of c23h22o
and the structure that we think it is is
shown down in the lower
right there
although this hasn't been confirmed but
this is the tentative match to that
particular molecular formula
given the insilico
program
so just to give you a couple specific
examples of things that are pulled out
from the ms finder
exercise these are two lc esi negative
on the left and two lc esi positive
compounds the red
spectral lines are the in silico
predicted fragments and the
black lines are the accurate mass
fragments measured in this
in this msms experiment that we
performed
between the inability to get a targeted
msns result for
these
samples
so there were many compounds we could
not obtain a targeted msms result for
and among the ones that we did get a
targeted msms there was often not enough
abundance to do very much with so
further efforts to concentrate select
purify would be helpful here and we're
working on
improving this set of the results
so where are we headed uh from here
first
we've proven that there are many things
in urban wildfire samples that were not
present in undeveloped
samples but based on the set of
bioassays we chose to apply here there's
not a systematic difference that that
those residential samples are more
bioactive and we also did not see any
systematic presence of the kinds of
compounds that you would see in a
typical environmental contaminants
database that is after this fire we
don't see a lot of residue of known
pesticides or known solvents
what we're seeing is
highly con
converted compounds that have been you
know subject to combustion
i think we can say that in this project
the gc
pathway yielded more success in
isolating and annotating compounds that
were related to the bio essay endpoints
and so for this purpose it was more
successful that
for other purposes it may not be
the same result obviously and then
there's the fundamental question about
whether we pick the right bioassays
there are many many different biological
endpoints that might be of concern and
it may be that the ones that we selected
are not the ones that we most need to
worry about and that's the challenge for
our toxicologists collaborators to
figure out what the right suite of
assays is to apply to these kinds of
samples
so i wanted to acknowledge the sources
of funding for this work
we had two
nih grants um that were focused on the
fires
the environmental health sciences core
center at uc davis provided some pilot
funding for wildfire analysis and a an
r21 grant from nih also provided funding
specifically to study this set of fires
so it was a rapid response grant
following the 2017 fires and as i
mentioned a lot of the methods that i
talked about here were developed under
the auspices of our superfund research
center
that's cited here
i didn't list them on the authors but as
you'll see in a minute they're an author
on the paper that we recently published
the west coast metabolomic center has
been really helpful
in helping my lab adapt and transform ms
dial and ms finder for these
kinds of applications and in particular
claibosis and oliver fien have
been really critical to this effort
and so now i want to close by just
making a plug
just two days ago our paper that covers
the work that i talked about here was
accepted for publication and
environmental science and technology
i can't tell you any more than that
because i don't even have the proofs for
the paper yet but you should look for it
shortly the citation is below
it'll be out
in a couple of days possibly by the by
the time this thing actually airs
because i'm recording it ahead of time
uh so i look forward to um addressing
any questions that you might have about
this um following the presentation and i
thanks
thank you for your attention and
interest in the work